في الضاحيه الجنوبيه ببيروت استشهد نائب
رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس صالح
العاروري وقياديين بكتائب القسام قبل
معركه طوفان الاقصى في السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي بعده اشهر بدا الاهتمام الاسرائيلي
بتصفيه صالح العاروري حيث يراه مسؤولون
اسرائيليون مسؤولا عن محاولات لاشعال ما
قالوا انها شراره انتفاضه جديده في الضفه
الغربيه عام
1966 ولد صالح محمد سليمان العاروري في
قريه عروره برام الله وحصل على بكالوريوس
في الشريعه الاسلاميه من جامعه الخليل
ساهم العاروري في تاسيس كتائب عز الدين
القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس في
الضفه الغربيه ويعد احد ابرز الرؤوس
المدبره لتسليح اعتقل صالح العاروري اكثر
من 18 سنه في السجون الاسرائيليه وعندما
افرج عنه في المره الاخيره عام 2010 ابعد
خارج فلسطين واختير عضوا في المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس ثم نائبا لرئيس المكتب
السياسي للحركه في اكتوبر
2017 كان العاروري احد اعضاء الفريق
المفاوض لاتمام صفقه شليط المعروفه بوفاء
الاحرار والتي تمت عام
2011 في الحدي من اكتوبر الماضي فجرت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منزل عائله صالح
العاروري بعد اسابيع من بدء الحرب الحاليه
ياتي استشهاد العاروري في سياق تهديدات
اسرائيليه متواليه باستهداف قاده حماس
بالداخل والخارج لكن وقوع العمليه في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه في بيروت قد يدخل بالحرب
الراهنه في منعطفات جديده
وخطيره